(graphic whooshes)
- You know, the amount of giving
that is being done in the world
that is disguised as manipulation
to get something that
you want after you give,
is the reason that giving
has cynicism around it.
(intense dramatic music)
♪ Yeah. ♪
- You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
First, I just wanna thank
everybody for being here,
I'm sure there's, you coulda been anywhere
in the world tonight,
but you decided to be
here, so I appreciate that.
I'd love to do as much
Q and A as possible,
and I think for anybody in the audience,
whatever the questions
are and whatever genres.
If you wanna talk about the
New York Jets American Football
that is something that I can
speak to, (audience laughs)
or anything else you'd
like to speak to about.
But you know, just having
a sense of the audience
and knowing there's a
mix of entrepreneurship
and a mix of corporate
In this journey that you're going through,
I'm always fascinated when
someone does something,
I think that the most interesting
things I see in the world
are more based on counter-punching skills,
than they are on the game plan you had
going into the fight, right?
I think the ability to
recognize the collateral
from your movement as a
person or as an organization
or as a business and contextualizing it
to the reality of what's
happening, not the hypothesis
or thesis you came into it,
is super duper important
and I would argue a very
important thing for every person
in this room, whether
professionally or personally,
to think about, because
that's then practical
instead of pontificating or a hypothesis.
For you, going through
this, you start something,
you start a hashtag, you
know, if you met me on day one
and said, hey, I'm gonna do this hashtag,
I woulda been like,
bro, don't do a hashtag.
Hashtags are not ownable.
Like, you can put it
out there, but right now
I can use your hashtag
to siphon the people
that are paying attention
to that to sell a razor.
I could.
They're not ownable but
what I wanted to ask,
that I felt could bring the
most value to this group,
is what's been the biggest surprise
as you've gone through this journey?
Like what did you
ideology-wise have in your head
three years ago that's just
fundamentally different today?
Yeah, so that's a really
good point because for me,
I guess that's what I can hands up say
I did not have going into
this is like that kickback,
questions, I just went in with an idea
and went out and started
executin' it and that was that.
But the biggest surprise
for me has been for sure
the tiniest amount of people
have kicked up against this.
And I mean that in a way of
like the competitive world
of charity and business and
all kinds of different things,
I've felt almost zero
competition in what I'm doing.
And although it's super important, too,
I've thought plenty of times, it's like,
yeah, it's just a hashtag,
anyone could do something
with nothing and do
what they want with it,
but I kinda want them to do that.
I want them to go ahead
and do exactly that.
And I suppose there's enough
populatin' this already
that you can see what it's
about, and I feel so lucky
in the fact that there's
already enough of a journey
to go, if someone tried to come
in and it wasn't authentic,
I think it would be ratted
out pretty much immediately.
But the biggest surprise, honestly,
has been the small
amount of haters I've had
is quickly transitioned into
people I feel like people
who see this for what it is.
And I don't think that's anything
to do with me personally,
I think it's just that I'm
not trying to shout at anyone.
I'm just saying here's how I'm doing it,
just playing that amplifier
and it seems to have worked.
- That's great.
- Sounds like a bit of
a bullshit way to say,
oh, nothing's gone wrong, that's
the biggest surprise but--
(audience laughs)
- Well, I speak about that, too.
I think nothing goes wrong when
you don't have expectation.
- Yeah, right, right.
- You know, I think people have
a lot of things going wrong
because they fucking expected something.
It's why people struggle with giving.
Giving is giving on the person
that you're giving it to terms, not yours.
The amount of giving that
is being done in the world
that is disguised as
manipulation to get something
that you want after you give is the reason
that giving has cynicism around it.
It's not giving, it's manipulation.
- Yeah.
- Something to share, we were just jamming
a little bit upstairs, something
that I've been affected by
in just giving or social
good, we got into brands
and business talk a little
bit, is that the biggest issue
to me about companies and social good
have not been the biggest
companies in the world.
It's been the startups who are using good
as a front to their financial ambitions.
The amount o' companies
after TOMS was successful,
I personally, and I was kind
of slowing down my investing
during this period, I
personally sat through
40 to 70 pitches where the
person walked in and said
some sob story about why
they were so passionate
about the redheaded ant,
you know, the insect
in Afghanistan and how every
time somebody bought this cola,
they would donate a cola
to that ant, or the kid,
or this and that, and then
when I looked at the economics
around the business, they
weren't giving jack shit,
they inflated the price
of the product so much
that they were able to
make their full margin
and then give back
whatever they were, I mean,
as we all know, there's been
plenty of buy one give one,
and it got me so cynical to the majority
of the altruistic entrepreneur
who was using good
as a front and I think we
have a lot of understanding
that when big brands do
things, we're always cynical,
but to me, they've been
dramatically better social players
than the entrepreneurs
who are out there fronting
that they're saving the world
but they really just give a
shit about their economics.
- Yeah, and I think, I see
so many people day-to-day
in the work I do, like, I
see people really killing it
all the time and no eyes
are on them whatsoever.
Like I see people who are
absolutely smashing it
in their communities every single day
and no eyes are on them.
And I think that actually I agree
and that's what we were saying upstairs,
I think when you have a front
and it kind of hasn't got the guts
and anything else to offer,
I think it is even worse
because then you're
using something as a mask
that really shouldn't be used as a mask.
It's really about people
and it's about one another
so I think the way I've
the brands are turning
and helping is being able
to find those change makers,
being able to find those individuals
who are already doing
it in their communities
and being able to highlight
them and support them in a way.
Because I meet so many
people who need that support
but they are just, they're just doin' it
and they're not expecting it,
but they could probably do
a hell of a lot more if
they had that engine.
So yeah, I think it's important
to kind of recognize those people
maybe who are already, and as
far as having too many ideas
going in, maybe people do.
I don't know, I've had that experience
where people have maybe
had this foolproof plan
about how they're gonna
give and I guess for me,
it's just about going out there
and I just talk to people.
I just have a conversation.
(audience members laugh)
You know, that's what I think,
literally, I'm not doing anything.
I'm up here because of a journey.
I talk to people.
I have a conversation.
I look, I say hello to people.
That's what I do, you know?
- Yes, I think one of
the fascinating things
about some pretty uncomfortable,
you know, it's funny,
I'm so comfortable publicizing
I wanna buy a sports franchise,
but I'm outrageously uncomfortable
and a lot of my inner circle's curious
about I'm uncomfortable
talking about the things I do
in nonprofit, I once had to, after I got
into a huge Twitter rant seven years ago,
meet somebody at a Starbucks
and show them my tax return
because I got into this,
like, tiff. (audience laughs)
Nonetheless, why I bring
that up is I'm fascinated
by what people want to talk
about, don't want to talk about,
and I think that's up to everybody
but in that same parallel, the thing
that became more obvious
to me is it's stunning
that at this point in my
life, it's far more easy
for me to write a check to a nonprofit
than sit on the boards that
I'm on or actually give time,
right, and I think, and by
the way, when I say that,
I had a friend who heard me
say that in some podcast,
and he like hit me up.
I got on the phone with him, he's like,
man, I feel bad, I should
start actually giving time.
I'm like, bro, I'll be honest with you,
plenty of organizations need money.
Like this is not about one or the other,
it's just like what do you have to give.
A lot of startup people are
like, I don't have money.
I'm like, you have your time.
You wanna build a business
and you have no money?
Good news, you have your time.
Like, go reply to every
single person on Twitter
talking about your topic.
That's what I did.
You know, you got one or
the other and I think,
when I think about giving I
think a lot about time or money,
just like I do with businesses
and I think that's an
interesting 'nother thing
that I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about.
- Yeah, and I'm so glad
you touched on that
'cause it's like, you're
identifying what your time is
and how it's best given as
well, like a lot of people
message me and get in
touch with me and be like,
yo, I wanna come out
with you on the street
and hang out, or like, let's
go out and give, give, give
on the street, people, and I'm
like, there's this guy Franco
who's here tonight who's helping me.
He just came out of the
woodwork from nowhere
and he's like, I'm an editor.
Someone introduced me, I'm
like, that's so valuable.
Oh my God, I've got someone to help me
edit some stuff for the first time ever.
I'm like, oh God, that's incredible.
I mean, I'm just sayin',
that's just one example
of like you and your time can
be spent in all kinds of ways
that's gonna again, bring
people up and kinda help,
like direct help is--
- This goes back to giving.
It's funny, because I'm sure
you get hit up by people
who are like, hey, I
wanna go out with you.
- Mm hmm, yeah.
And because what they want is
they wanna go out with you,
take a selfie with you, get the awareness
that they were with you
because they think you're cool
or it's cool and that's
what they're actually
trying to accomplish.
This goes back to giving on
the other person's terms.
I mean, I literally get 700 emails a month
when somebody knows I'm
gonna be in some town,
like Gary, like in the title, great news,
I will pick you up from the airport
and drive you to your hotel.
I wanna really give.
I'm like, fuck you, motherfucker.
(audience laughs)
I'm like, that's $48 Uber ride.
I need my peace and quiet
to catch up with the work
when I land from the flight.
You don't wanna give me a ride.
You want me to give you fucking consulting
for 45 minutes while we drive.
You can save your lunch
that you wanna buy for me
and all that, and I'm fascinated
by, and a lotta times,
I'll hit up those kids, they're
like, yo, it's not working.
I'm like, 'cause you're not giving.
When you're DMing somebody, you're asking.
You're tryin' to take.
It's a really funny thing to
try to get somebody to click
on what the definition of giving is
and people struggle with
selflessness, they really do.
They struggle with not being selfish
in the disguise of giving.
The reason I wanna talk about it
and keep throwing out these examples is
once you're aware of
it, people aren't even,
oftentimes aren't aware.
You know, but once you become aware of it,
I actually think it changes
the entire framework of this conversation.
- I think giving, whether I
use selflessness or giving,
for me it's like, what do you want?
Right, if I'm gonna give or if
I'm doing something for you,
it can't be what I think you need.
It can't be what I have to give you
or what's convenient for me to give you.
It has to be what you want, what you need.
The other party, if you're giving,
the other party needs that thing.
And so that's the part that keeps playing
over and over in my head.
Two core things I'm fascinated
by is people are great
at giving when they have something to give
but if the other person doesn't
want it, that's not giving.
And then, much scarier to me,
the one that I'm most cynical to,
is I'm gonna give to you right now
because I have something I want from you,
even if you're strategic and
in three and a half years,
there's something I want from you.
I don't mind if somebody's thoughtful
and can conceive that there
may be, I even do that.
I do things that like,
oh, this could, it's that I don't expect.
- 100,000%.
- You know what's funny,
I've thought about that a little bit.
I'm not sure, but fuck, I'd
much rather that be the case
than the alternative, right?
I'd much rather people struggle
with how they're giving
versus having a loaded
gun on their giving.
You know what I mean?
I think that, you know,
for me, I've come to learn
that I like admiration.
I want a statue, I
don't want money, right?
(audience laughs)
So my selfishness is
that I want to be admired
and liked and appreciated, and thus,
I've defaulted into giving, right?
You know, in whatever
way I think about it.
But yeah, I think it's a very interesting,
you know what's fun?
'Cause I know there's a lot
of business people here,
it's how I market.
I think it's all very tied together.
It's being consumer-centric,
it's being human-centric.
I think giving is a
really important concept
because I think the way
people have it framed
is so much more selfish.
I'm gonna share something
I've shared very few times in my life.
- (woman murmurs)
- That's right.
(audience laughs)
Probably the single biggest
disappointing moment
in my life of something I
absolutely did not see at all
and when I was faced with
it, just like took the wind
out of my body was when I
started joining nonprofit boards
and realized almost everybody
was there to network
with people to do shit in the
outside world in business,
not because they were
there for the giving.
I wrote a book called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
for a very specific reason.
I thought the best way to
market is to give, give, give
and then ask and not expect.
Not give, give, give and then take.
When you give, you give.
When you're asking, you're asking.
Don't be half pregnant in your giving.
Don't be half pregnant in your ask
when you wanna sell something.
It just crushed me.
And you know, it was like
literally the second meeting I ever had.
First one was a little weird.
Second one, I kinda looked around
during like, you know, it's
a three-hour board meeting,
we're trying to save,
build schools in Ghana,
and then I'm just listening to
what everybody's actually saying
when they're grabbing fruit
or going for a pee break
and I'm like, fuck.
It crushed me.
And then I saw it again heavily
when TOMS was successful,
that was very obvious to me.
And I see companies doing it all the time.
Companies are trying to be
good, or be more diverse,
or do the right thing, they're companies.
They're trying to make money.
And like we sense it but
I think we are cynical
to big companies and I think
we need to be more thoughtful
about individual humans
'cause humans are hiding.
Humans are hiding and I
think if humans understood
how life actually works, which
is when you have something
to give and you give and you
give without expectation.
When you truly, right?
I mean, this is what
I sensed from our jam.
I think it's working for you
'cause you literally have
no fuckin' expectation.
- Yeah, my only expectation is literally
when I go to sleep at
night, I'm just, like,
my expectation is that
guy I've seen that day
and how he felt and how I felt.
Like, it's so low and I know some people
who are like, my benchmark is so low
on what is a good day for me.
And that sounds really awful
but it's really, really not.
It's just that I set it somewhere that,
it's completely based
on my own expectation.
And that's exactly
where it is, but for me,
I just see, I see havin'
time for one another,
whether that's a company or
whether that's an individual,
I just think, I guess it's harder to see
with a bigger brand like,
I know it needs a bit more
of a buffer to be able to,
like we've all seen those
campaigns that go wrong
and like we've questioned them
and I think sometimes that
does need a buffer and a bridge
and I've been in positions before
where I have been like, should I do this
because I don't know whether
that ruins what I'm doing
and it is a difficult place but I know
that it's definitely worth
creatin' more of a space
for these things and that's
why I wanted to kind of lead
and ask you, Gary, as well.
What do you feel, as far
as putting this stuff out,
like I put this stuff out on
social media all the time.
My Instagram is full of
this stuff I'm doin',
where I'm like, I'm doing
something for someone else.
And obviously, that's a very kinda like,
some of you might be thinking now,
it's like, oh, nice
one, man, this is great,
but like, telling a
hell of a lot of people
about how nice you're being to someone.
And I try to keep it somewhere
that's very much about,
like I said, these people, but I think--
- I think, you know, I'm just gonna
jump in, I apologize--
- Yeah, yeah go for it.
- I think it's intent.
I think it's intent.
Like, Gary, you're such a narcissist.
All your content is you.
I'm like, I'm trying to
say something to people
that I hope they take and
I expect nothing from them,
I ask nothing of them,
and I hope they take it
and do something with it.
That is the form of how I
know how to communicate it.
I'm sorry I'm in the video.
(audience laughs)
If you were trying to
get everybody to watch
so that everybody here
thought you were the best guy,
so then you could
rope-a-dope 'em and get 'em
into some sort of like
$5,000-a-month club to be good,
then you're a dick face.
(audience laughs softly)
If you don't, and you live
your life and you do it
and then you die, you're the best.
I'm not joking.
I think intent is the thing,
I put my head on the pillow,
I think I'm gonna make mistakes every day.
I will make mistakes, I am a human.
I will do things that
are wrong, I am a human.
I will say I'm sorry when I'm wrong.
I will take losses when I deserve them,
but the intent is fucking amazing.
It's why I'm so fuckin' calm.
It's why I'm happy as fuck.
It's why I'm so grateful.
It's why I'm able to give,
'cause I'm so fulfilled
that like, I give out of
guilt and gratitude, right?
Like I'm just, I know exactly
what's happening with me
and I'm trying to get people
to change their perspective,
but I'm really not trying,
like I like the feeling
of somebody getting benefit
from something you said,
that's what, I'm sure
that gets you excited.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Watching somebody
go do something meaningful
'cause they thought it was cool
that you got somebody,
that's an incredible feeling.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
Yeah, it gives me all
the hope in the world.
That's what motivates me
to carry on doing this.
Every time someone takes
this and does their own thing
with it, that's exactly it.
So I agree, I think that's--
- The thing that I admire
about you in the limited time
and context I have for you
that I think is important
to make me palpable that
I would highly recommend
people think about is what
is your level of humility?
I said it in the 4Ds just now with some,
I really meant it, like if I die tomorrow,
I think I'll have a good three-hour run
on social media where everybody will share
their favorite piece
o' content or whatever,
whatever it might be.
And literally every single person
that is even my superest fan
and consumes me 30 hours a day,
a week later will be on to their life.
And I think when you actually,
like I'm trying to, fuck,
I wanna impact 7.7 billion people.
That is my ambition.
My ambition is to share what
my mom did so well with me
and pass it on and my mom,
my dad, and my circumstances,
but really, my fuckin' mom,
the way she parented me
in that optimism and positivity
but with accountability, right?
That balance, which I think
we've lost in modern parenting,
if I can share that, impact people,
get them into perspective,
I push out my content like
400 trillion to one, look.
Who likes math in here?
You should be happy as fuck.
Because when I tell you
that your likelihood
of being born is 400 trillion to one
and you go and do the math behind it
and actually accept the
modern science behind this,
which is 400 trillion to one.
If you actually wrap your fuckin' head
around the fact that we're all humans
and we're sitting here right now
and the likelihood of that
is literally impossible.
I don't know, all of a
sudden, shit gets happy.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Woman] Mm hmm.
- I'm being serious.
I'm being real serious.
People are like why are you so happy.
I'm like, if 13 people didn't die today,
everything else is manageable.
And I really live my life that
way, but that's perspective.
And that lets you, but that is my goal.
My goal is the wiring and
serendipity of my DNA,
now that there's an
internet, I'm like, fuck it,
let me share it at scale.
I enjoy it, I like getting
stopped at the airport
and somebody saying, you, like I love it,
and I'm gonna do it,
and I wanna reach all 7.7 billion people.
I mean it with all my heart.
And I mean this, and I think I can,
and I might, and I really mean that.
And I also think I mean jack shit.
And once you get that fuckin'
balance, shit gets good.
And I think that's what you have.
I mean that.
- Yeah, man, I appreciate it,
and I feel so much the same.
That's kind of what I meant
about my benchmark being low
is that my ambition is super high.
Like equally, I wanted
to get this out there
to thousands and thousands of people.
I want this to be a
continued global movement.
I feel amazing every time I see it grow.
But my benchmark is low in
the sense that I am here.
I'm like wakin' up each day
and in those small moments we have,
which is just literally being aware
for one another each
day, the way we interact
with one another each day
is where it's at for me.
- Fuck, I just thought of something.
Three days ago,
(audience laughs)
DRock, you around?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Good.
So three days ago, one of
the most interesting things
happened, just on this
point that you're making.
I was getting out of the
car and I looked at the guy
who was sitting in a truck
and he was like a rugged-looking dude.
And I looked at him and I
smile and he smiled back at me.
And I just remember thinking,
like, 'cause I do it all the,
I'm just happy and I fucking
love smiling at people
(audience laughs)
because one, I live in New
York, (audience laughs)
and so like, that just fucks
with people in general, but
(audience laughs)
it is one of the, you know,
it's the much more
lightweight micro version
of what you're saying, but it is stunning
how much people enjoy if you
look them dead in the eye
while walking by them in
the airport or on the street
and smile at them, how
stunningly warm the reaction is
by people and I think like,
I think about these things
'cause I'm like, okay, if I
start really pushing this,
well then it's gonna
become a tactic, and it,
you know, but then I'm
like, back to your question,
like giving too much, I'm
like, but that's still good.
'Cause that's better than not doing.
I think about this shit all the time
but I don't know, it hit me so hard.
I don't know why it was this time.
I don't know what the hell I sensed
or you know, what was going on.
It was just, it really
like shook, like, you know,
like I get goosebumps, I
like feel shit sometimes.
I was like, this was good.
There was something there.
I remember thinking
where the fuck's DRock?
We should have filmed this
and I think this is
an important topic--
- Yeah, yeah.
- I really do think this
is an important topic.
And by the way, I think the
macro anxiety and tension
in our world today, politically,
I think is a tremendous thing.
I just want everybody to know.
I think it's a tremendous thing.
One man's point of view.
- Yeah.
- Because I think it's
our one step backwards
for two steps forward, because
I think we're being exposed.
- Completely.
Yeah, man, and that's exactly it.
I feel like if you believe that,
which I think everyone in this room
will believe mental health is real,
will believe talking to one
another is more important,
then you gotta believe
that something like a smile
is the antidote to that
because that stuff is real.
And there's this guy I met, (murmurs)
near Victoria the other
day and he said to me,
he was like, you know
it's funny, when you like,
do something for someone
even if it's as small
as just talkin' or a smile,
like, you're not supposed
to get it back in that moment.
You're not supposed to
get it back right then
but they might wander round the corner
and they might like
give it to someone else
and he was saying this
really simplified way
and I'm like, yeah, that's it.
He knows exactly what it's about
and he hasn't overthought it.
He just knows if he gives it out there,
that's gonna ripple and that ripple
to the start of your day,
that can affect your creative,
your work rate, your success in every way.
I truly believe that.
I think that even though it sounds small
and sounds like, oh, we
might be feeling good now
'cause a smile's great but it's literally,
I think it's a very real--
- I'll tell you how real I think it is.
I think that 37 years ago,
which is five minutes ago,
if we're sitting here and
we're telling everybody here
that meditation's the shit,
we're some weird monks
from fuckin' India.
- [Man] Right, yeah.
- Now every cool fucking
hipster meditates every day
and it's the core of
their fuckin' existence.
- [Man] Okay.
- Right?
I mean this.
I think that it's really
funny, the timing of things
that are fuckin' completely
outlandish, the way we eat
and exercise and mental,
everything that we now think
is standard, cool, or right,
30 years ago was some left-field shit.
My entire fucking life
at this point secretly
is to trick 15- to 25-year-old alpha males
that nobody else can get to except me
and trick them into
understanding that kindness
and gratitude and
empathy is the foundation
of an alpha winner.
Sounds ridiculous now.
I know what's goin' on out there.
But I'm telling you, I can taste it.
I know it and I know I can
do it, or at least my part
and that builds momentum.
And we were talkin' upstairs, I said,
we were talkin' a little bit about scale
and I was like, just fuckin' execute.
I genuinely believe
that one woman, one man
just executing, just executing,
can actually impact a lot of people.
Because I think when
you do the right thing,
the amplification becomes inevitable.
I really believe that.
And I think now we live in a world
where so much is being
amplified naturally,
I think what we need to be careful of
when we get into great stuff like this
is the caricature of.
TOMS shoes can start
out actually giving back
but then the manifestation changes.
Social media originally
was a sharing ourselves,
now we're the PR agents of
ourselves on those platforms.
Like literally somebody here
is gonna go fucking hiking
this weekend just for the fuckin' photo.
(audience laughs)
You don't wanna hike.
You need the Instagram photo
showing that you're hiking.
So we as humans can
really become caricatures.
No question, the biggest
thing I talk to myself about
is do not become the
caricature of yourself
because of what's happening with you.
Which is why I don't consume,
do not get high on your
fuckin' own supply.
You're shit, just fuckin' execute.
Don't get caught up.
- Yeah I was gonna ask how
you keep in check with that
each day but I think you
already answered it then.
It's just like being accountable--
- I just genuinely know that
nobody's gonna give a fuck
when I die.
- Yeah, uh huh.
(laughs)
- I mean, it's super easy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's super easy not too get too high,
you can read, first of all,
I like reading my negative comments
way more than my positive ones.
I mean it.
And I don't think they're
trolls and haters.
I really don't.
I think that they've
consumed me in a context
and I need to be thoughtful
about what they're thinking.
Now I do believe, I equally believe,
that if you're taking time to
consume other people's content
on the internet and
then you have the energy
to leave terrible comments,
you're in a sad place yourself.
You know so usually when
I read, like, Gary Vee,
you're a snake oil salesmen,
my first default is
okay, why did they interpret
this content this way?
But even before I go there,
my alpha, even before that,
my first default is like I
feel bad for that person.
- Yeah, and you've just hit someone
who you wanna reach, right?
You know, in some ways, I--
- No, I understand what you're saying.
- If I relate that to what I'm doing, too,
if I get that comment where it's like,
oh yeah, but these people
should get a job
- (murmurs)
- And oh, they're drunks,
and oh, they're this thing
and that thing, I'm like, that's exactly
who I want to talk to.
Because otherwise I wouldn't
be doing what I'm doing.
Otherwise it's someone else
just nodding their head.
- I think that's right and I think also,
you just have to understand humans.
Humans only know two ways
to build the biggest building in town.
Most people's strategy of
building the biggest building
in town is by tearing down
everybody else's building.
There are few people who just
go out, put their head down,
and try to just build
the biggest building.
And I think that for whatever reason,
that thank God that moment
that my parents decided
to have sex and have a
child, (audience laughs)
that default DNA that
I have that I've never,
the thought of tearing down other people
for my success seems like such loser shit.
Like when I watch other
people try to tear down
the competitive landscape
for them to look big,
it's the biggest tell of a loser.
And a lotta people get
micro big wins in that.
That model works.
You could build a big building
and tear everybody, it works.
I think people get confused.
It works in the short term.
It's got no sustainability for legacy.
That person always loses in the end.
Always.
But people are caught
up in short-term ROI.
Because you're insecure
and you care about other people's opinion.
Like what is the balance of you genuinely
want to do something good
but you also have your own
whatever, ambitions or wants or needs,
I think one of the biggest
reasons I talk way more
about trying to buy the New York Jets
than I do about all the good things I do
is 'cause I think I've wanted
to speed up the interactions
of not, I don't mind that
people think what they think.
I think transparency matters.
I think most people's vulnerability
that are good humans are hiding
whatever selfish things
they want for themselves
'cause they think it
undermines their good.
And I think you can carry
two contradictory things
within a human being,
and I think your work,
your life's work will play out
and we will judge in the end.
I am outrageously
interested in being booed
in the third quarter,
I just wanna be cheered
when it's triple zero.
You understand?
People struggle with that
because it comes down
to self-esteem and insecurities
and many other things.
I tell everybody that I meet along the way
that I think is authentic,
put your two fingers in your ears,
execute in perpetuity and
let the fuckin' chips fall.
That's the only way you'll ever be able
to achieve something remarkable
because when you are
doing anything interesting
or game changing or
different, you're only gonna,
I've only been booed my whole life.
Every single thing I've
done, basically from school
to professionally, I mean, I don't know
if I've ever taken more
heat for not opening
a second liquor store with my dad.
The entire liquor industry,
which was my life, right?
My dad's liquor industry
in New Jersey was my life.
Every one of those
people fuckin' ridiculed
the shit out of me for selling
liquor on the computer.
(man laughs)
You're pouring all that money
in selling liquor on the computer?
You should open a second liquor store.
Right?
So I think there are certain people,
entrepreneurs, givers, politicians,
there's millions of
different kinds of, teachers,
there're certain people
who are just capable
of doing that and I think the
reason I talk a lot about it
is my hope is if this one fuckin' answer
can let 'em hear one less
voice, that's movin' the needle.
Because you're either on
offense or you're on defense.
And dwelling about other people's opinions
of how you live your life is defense.
And I wanna remind everybody,
the current state of
political correctness moves.
I have no interest in living my life
and parenting my children
on today's current state
of how you should raise your children.
You raise your children your
way, I'll raise mine mine.
Right, and I think that's something
that I think anybody doing
something has to navigate.
The other thing is, I try to
convince nobody of anything.
I've zero interest in convincing anybody
that anything I say is right.
Like zero.
People are always like, Gary,
how do you convince the
clients to do social media?
I'm like, I don't.
I tell them what I believe
and hopefully they'll
do something about it.
And if not, then I can't wait to see 'em
in seven years when I can
telL 'em, I told you so, dick.
(audience laughs)
I really feel like I win
either way every time.
I really feel like that's what happens.
I'll either be historically
correct and I'll razz you.
All these kids that are not signing
with VaynerSports right now, right,
'cause me and my brother
have this sports agency
and we're coming in second a lot
'cause they're enamored
but we're still new and
(sucks breath over teeth)
this agency that's been
doing it for 40 years
and did it for my favorite player
feels like a smarter bet, it's crazy.
I fuckin' love it.
There's a thing that came out about Kobe
and Dwyane Wade this
weekend where Dwyane Wade
was talkin' about how he broke Kobe's nose
in an All-Star game and
he called him a day later
and Kobe was like, no, no, I love it.
I love that you fuckin' broke my nose.
And then everybody was just
talkin' about how crazy
Kobe was and I was watching that video
and I was like, fuck,
I so understand that.
The only thing I like better
than winning a piece o'
business is losing it.
I genuinely enjoy it more.
- Yeah, man.
(laugh)
(audience laughs)
I just wanted to touch
(murmurs) and for me,
the best thing to do, man,
is when you feel that way
or the scenario you're
describing, get out your scales
and weigh up what feels better,
or what matters to you more
is a better way to phrase it,
the good you're doing and how that feels,
because, again, coming
back to your intent,
or those people who
are haters on this side
'cause guess what, you're
gonna be full up with that,
the reason why you're doing it.
- And by the way, back to hater.
I'm really getting passionate about this.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm almost doing this with all you guys.
(audience laughs)
I'm passionate about
this haters trolls thing.
I think people are quickly
defaulting immediately
if somebody doesn't agree with them
and calling them a troll or a hater,
and they may be, but
I genuinely mean this.
I take a lotta heat because
I put myself very out there.
But I genuinely have become great friends
with many people that shit on me
or have come to understandings.
It's very important to
be thoughtful, like look,
somebody who might say
you're a fucking jerk-off
and you're just trying
to build a business,
you don't know if their
aunt committed suicide
and that's hurt them in their heart
and they knew you before
you're been entrepreneur.
You know, we don't know.
I just don't think we know.
I don't know, I'm getting very
passionate about judgment.
I'm still in my working stages on it
but like, it's crazy.
I'm just, like, I have opinions.
I'm a normal human being.
I got hot takes on everything.
But I know they're bullshit.
Because even the people I know super well,
even DRock, who I know super well,
man, do I not know a lot.
And so if that's the
case, the hell am I doing
with your one piece o' content
or your one question or, right?
You can go on intuition,
all this, but I think
we need to be more
thoughtful about pushback
because it's been very helpful for me.
Like I think, I don't know,
I think it's important.
- Yeah, and I think through doing that,
you allow yourself that.
Like I wrote something
a couple of days ago
where I was saying to allow
for a stranger's bad day
is to allow for yours.
Like catch me on Monday
morning without a coffee.
Dear oh dear.
You know what I mean?
It's like I'm gonna be that person,
definitely this week or next or whenever.
And I think empathizing
with another is empathizing
with yourself and I think in the relation
to what we're sayin' with
comments, oh you're right,
I think labelin' it as
just haters is actually,
well, it's a human.
It's a human who is coming from this place
and that's that.
- I'll be honest with you,
most of the hate I get is
when I, if I'm very fair,
and really, I enjoy it and I think it's
why I am empathetic, I'm like look,
this person saw this clip
for one minute on Instagram.
It's the only thing they know about me.
I hit their explore page.
I'm very self-aware of my
different personality traits
and when I have the mic and you don't,
I've got way more fire
and bravado and energy
than if we're just sitting one-on-one.
And it's only a minute and if I didn't
contextualize it perfectly,
it can be out of context
and me out of context
is a fucking disaster.
(audience laughs)
As are most people.
Especially with me, with
passions and opinions.
Out of context, big fuckin' trouble.
And so I can see it through their eyes.
And then there's also people
that don't have vested
interest in you being right.
If you sell television
commercials in America,
you don't love me.
- [Audience Member] No.
- You know, like, and that's fine.
And that's fair.
I try to have a conversation
with those people.
I have a lot of friends who sell things
that I don't believe in
and we'll have a beer
and I'm like, look, do
you actually believe it?
Because some of my
friends actually believe
that buying a television
commercial in 2019
is the best use of money
to make something happen.
That I love.
That means we just have
different points of view.
My bigger problem is you're
an SVP at a TV company,
you're bonused on that business,
and you're only saying it
because that's what
you're currently selling.
And next month, when
you're an SVP at Facebook,
you're shitting on TV.
That I've got a problem with.
Not really, live your life.
You're just not gonna win the long game
'cause you won't be historically correct
so you're gonna damage your
brand, your reputation,
and I think that matters.
I'm very proud of saying
what I believe in.
I'm not gonna always be right,
but I've never said anything
I don't believe in for
financial vested interest,
which is why I don't feel vulnerable.
My number one thing I can't wait for
in the world right now
in the micro and business
is when I decide that
social media's overpriced.
Like, can't wait.
If Cambridge Analytica didn't happen,
it might have happened sooner
but I think I still got
three to five years.
But in nine years, with no
hair, you're gonna see me
on whatever the Instagram of the day is
and I'm gonna be like, you're
buying fuckin' Instagram,
you asshole? (audience laughs)
And I can't wait because
that's when I'll be able
to go full circle because a lotta things
that I struggle with in marketing today
are the things I used to build my library.
Banner?
I used to get 14% click throughs
on winespectator.com in 1997.
14, like, I loved banner ads.
But I don't like them
anymore (audience chuckles)
and things change.
And so the Yellow Pages
was the fuckin' best.
That's why everybody calls their company
triple A everything,
'cause you showed up first.
But shit changes.
But I do think this subject
we're hitting on tonight
is going to be next.
I think there's gonna be
a lot more conversation.
I think we're having
a layered conversation
around kindness, giving,
that's starting to manifest
and that's why I was
excited to do tonight.
Who's got questions?
Give 'em the mic.
- [Man] So I wanted to
know your opinion on
if there was, for example,
you could create a company
that actually made income helping people
where you could then turn
that income and reinvest it
into creating other forms
of ways of helping people.
Is that not something
that would be a positive
way of doing something?
- I'll let you answer as well.
You can give it to him.
My hot read on that is first and foremost,
everybody should do
whatever the fuck they want.
Like my opinion means jack shit.
My point of view is for
me, for me, just me,
I like to build things that are business
and then I get profits and
with some of those profits,
I like to do good things.
I like separation.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
If Blake, who's a great
friend, did TOMS shoes
in the way that he liked
and many people argue
which one has more scale.
Whichever one has more scale
is whoever executed better at their thing.
Bill Gates made a lot of money
and is giving it all away
and so is Warren Buffett.
That's plenty o' fuckin' scale.
TOMS will never sell enough shoes
to beat Warren Buffett in his giving back.
So I think it's about self-awareness.
What makes you happy and
what you think is right.
- [Man] I think what it is,
I'm actually creating something
around loneliness at the moment.
I'm working with
Westminster and the elderly,
working how it all can
kinda connect together.
And obviously there's an
outlay to start this off
to where I'm going--
- Yep.
I've been doing that myself
but it will get to a point--
- Yep.
- Where you've gotta try and continue it.
So to be able to turn this into a form
of income where then--
- I got it.
- It can continue
to run itself or helping
more people to expand--
- I got it.
- It kinda--
- I think the question is, please.
- No, no, sorry, man.
I was gonna say, is the
question, am I right in thinking
is it, you mean like morally?
- [Man] Yeah, because--
- Because like the morality,
is it okay to be--
- [Man] Life science.
- Yeah, for sure.
I mean, of course you can earn,
I mean, 'cause otherwise,
you're never gonna be able
to complete what you wanna complete.
Like finances and resources
are what's needed.
I'm slowly starting to realize that,
(audience laughs)
to keep doing what I'm doing.
Like gradually, gradually, you know,
and I think morally, of course, man, I--
- But who gets to be the moral compass?
- Yeah, whose is it, right.
Whose--
- Like who, us two idiots?
- Yeah.
- Like, what?
- That's what I think
everybody has to,
like who?
- Yeah.
For me, personally,
it's when I go to sleep,
do I feel good about myself to myself.
- Yeah.
- I'm the judge and jury,
not my mom, not my wife,
not my kids, and
definitely not you fuckers.
(man laughs)
Me.
Me for me.
That's why I love the Rocky
with fuckin' Drago, right?
It's a moment that stuck with me as a kid
and now, 30 fuckin' years
later, I understand it.
When he's standing there
and he's telling the
fucking Soviet government,
you motherfuckers weren't in the ring.
I was fighting for myself,
not for you and this country.
I didn't understand.
I thought it's 'cause I was born in Russia
and I loved the Rocky movies,
but 25 years later, somehow on some,
during a shower or a flight,
I don't remember when I understood,
I'm like fuck, that's why
13-year-old fuckin' me
thought that was such an important moment.
I'm playin' for me.
I'm the fuckin' judge and the jury, right?
And how will I know
that I'm not delusional?
By how humans interact with me, right?
When people say to me, well,
Gary, well if that's the case,
how do you not become
insular and delusional
and how do you know?
I know by how people react.
But how I make decisions is me.
And I think that's what
he's gonna deal with.
When you start on these
things, it's judgment.
It's the judgment.
You only know.
It's only binary, brother.
There is no half pregnant.
Either you're doin' this
because you actually wanna give,
you're doing this because
you wanna give and make,
or you're doing this
'cause you wanna disguise
giving to really make.
There's only three moves.
That's it.
And you're the only
person that's gonna know.
And I keep tellin' kids all the time,
you may be able to trick the 98%,
but it's the 2% that know exactly
what the fuck you're doing
that you're eventually gonna wanna win
and you've lost because
you've gone short-term.
This gentleman with the beard.
- [Man] Yeah, sorry, I was just gonna say,
I mean, I'm a cynic at heart.
(murmurs)
(Gary and audience laugh)
- Yeah, I get it.
- [Man] And I worry that
altruism is just not real.
- I get it.
- [Man] And if we look for
any reason as to why they're
benefiting the person doing it,
you will find one.
- Yes.
- [Man] But on that same
vein, does that matter
if you're doing good for someone?
So with your loneliness
cause, do it, make profit,
help more people that are lonely.
That's only a good thing.
I don't don't see how it
could be a bad thing ever.
And likewise, with yourself, Josh,
what you're doing is
fantastic but you need
to make money to carry on doing that.
(murmurs) so make that money.
- Don't like, you're thinking,
this guy's a tosser.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] It's all moral no
matter what are you doing.
- No, mate, I'm joking, I'm sorry.
Yeah, exactly.
I agree with you, I agree with you.
But in answer to your, so altruism,
do you mean whether it's real as in like
are you always kinda constantly thinking,
I don't know whether this is legit,
'cause I don't know whether--
- Yeah, that's what a cynic--
- Someone's doing this for--
- At heart is.
- [Man] Yeah, it's in your
own head, like you said.
You know, only you know.
- Yeah.
So, right.
Right, right.
- [Man] Nobody
can judge you how--
- You know
what's really fun?
- [Man] Do it.
- And what's really funny
for me is I have parents
that are literally polar opposites.
My dad is a 100% default cynic.
My mom is a 100% optimist
and I understanded both.
So I look at everything
through both of their eyes.
And so I understand.
To be honest, I'm grateful
that I skew more towards optimism.
It's what entrepreneurship needs.
You're blindly optimistic.
Like, you can't do the
shit an entrepreneur does
unless you're delusional
and optimistic, right?
(audience laughs)
But I was so grateful that
I got into my dad's sphere
of cynicism, right,
because what it did was
it allowed me not to become delusional
and there was a level of practicality
that over-layered it, but to your point,
look, my macro on this is very simple.
Human beings would have been gone
a long, long, long, long, long time ago
if we weren't massively by default good.
It's crazy that we're still around.
By how smart we are as animals.
It's crazy, actually,
But I get it, I understand.
And I think to your point,
and I think, you know,
it's interesting just even
listening to you talk.
I think there's a, you
know, some of these words
that we all throw around,
somebody did something great
for me, they said, hey
Gary, you use empathy
a lotta times when you're
actually saying sympathy, right?
And I was like, oh, that's interesting,
you know, I kinda, it caught me, right?
I looked and I'm like, oh, that's true.
I don't know, I think
practicality is amazing.
I think I'm crazy practical.
It's why for 25 years,
I've built businesses,
never borrowed money, never lost money.
I'm always practical.
And I think that's a kissing
cousin sometimes to cynicism.
And I think, you know, I
have a friend who's like,
I'm cynical and I'm
like, you're practical.
(woman laughs)
You've got a little hint of cynicism.
And I think, you know, I'm optimistic
but I'm not delusional.
- [Man] I mean to take that cynicism
in a positive way.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Don't worry
about what you're doing.
If you're doing a good for a good cause.
(murmurs) but--
- [Man] Hang on, stop.
- Yeah, but you know what's
funny, back to definitions
and why words and wordsmithing matters
and I always think about it.
If you ask me, like literally cynicism
is the single thing in
the world I hate the most.
To just default into the
negative or by definition
feels like, sucky, but
if it's practicality,
just like I used empathy
as sympathy at times,
I'm curious, right?
Defaulting into no, that's fucked up,
they're tricking everybody, like,
everyone's drinking the
Kool-Aid, that's cynicism.
Hey, watch out for, you know,
so those are just things I think about.
- [Man] Yes, Gary, welcome
to London (murmurs).
- Thank you, (murmurs).
- Yes.
- [Man] (murmurs) and all that.
- Yep.
And it's kinda like losing its kinda value
'cause they've almost been doin' it daily.
Yeah, so it's a great question.
One, it's like the best
for, I meant the fact
that people call other human
beings their DRock at scale
always makes me smile,
so I like love that.
You know, couple things.
I remember the three months
that I debated with myself
if I wanted a man to follow me around
with a camera everywhere I went.
As self-confident as I am,
as much as I have my fingers
in my ears, as much as I don't give a fuck
of what you guys think,
I'm also not tone deaf.
I was like, holy shit. (audience chuckles)
If I'm gonna start walking
everywhere with a man
with a camera on me, boy
is everyone gonna think
I'm a narcissistic fuck,
you know? (audience laughs)
And so I had ta think it through
and I'm giving you the answer
to my question in story form.
The biggest reason I actually
finally took the plunge
and said fuck it, let's go,
after DRock was kinda pitching
it and kinda whatever,
'cause we knew vlogging was happening,
but it was all Casey and
others, first person.
This was different.
Was 'cause I remember
thinking, you know what?
I'm so happy that my great-great-grandkids
are gonna have this.
I lost both my grandfathers
before I got to know them.
The thought that by
chance either one of them
would've done a vlog for
four years and I could watch
and I'm a big history
will tell you the future,
it woulda just been so valuable.
Every entrepreneur right
now who's vlogging,
who she or he thinks they're
gonna make it like me,
who don't have the talent
or things of that nature.
I don't think anything's
ever oversaturated
'cause I don't think the
world's about being first.
I think the world's about being best.
I really do.
So that doesn't bother me,
if everyone's doing it.
I think in 13 years from now,
way more people are gonna be doing it.
Like way, way, more.
I think the fact that the booby prize,
that the booby prize of
you documenting yourself
for seven years, that you didn't pop,
and you didn't become a public speaker
or your company didn't get
huge, but the booby prize
is that your grandchildren
are gonna have it,
is one of the best things I
think I've ever done in my life.
I really believe that.
- [Man] And I think as well,
I've got a 21-year-old works for me.
- You do?
- Yeah (murmurs).
- Oh, that works for you.
(audience laughs)
I was like, man, you look fucking great.
Black definitely doesn't crack.
You look great, bro. (laughs)
- [Man] There was a point
when I thought that, great,
'cause I start getting to followers,
start getting the views
and stuff like that.
And it's that state of
mind, your whole thing
about patience as well, he could
see yourself in a lot of stress
because you see this
21-year-olds on YouTube
driving these Lamborghinis,
things like that.
And I'm thinking,
come on (murmurs).
- You know that's
who I'm going after.
You know that's what I'm going after.
Living a life where
you're comparing yourself
to somebody else, fuckin' sucks.
- It's mental.
It's a mad idea, isn't it?
- It's just devastating.
And that's why I have so much cynicism
towards the people that rent Lamborghini
to make it look like they
own it to then sell kids
because this is going to
be a mental health issue.
My number one fear, no question,
is what's about to happen.
I know that I'm gonna have to
go through a period of time
where people are gonna blame me for things
that I had nothing to do with
because entrepreneurship
at scale is going to fail
during the next economy
collapse and a lot of people
are not going to be able
to deal with the following.
Right now, on your Instagram account,
it says you're an entrepreneur.
You're manipulating your
creative on your Instagram
so you're showing when you're at parties
or when you're with somebody
cool or the worst of the worst,
you're taking $5,000
o' cash outta the bank
and taking a picture of you holding it all
or you know, normal
cliche alpha male things
and females, too, but you know,
and the world's gonna melt
and you're gonna have to go
from being this successful
entrepreneur on Instagram
to going and getting a job.
My fear is that there are a lot of people
that are not gonna have
the mental strength
to walk around with that scarlet letter.
When you're gonna have to go there
and you're gonna have
to deal with that post,
'cause you haven't posted
for four months on Instagram
'cause you're not showing
your Lambo anymore,
and the comments start streaming in,
like, yo bro, like just the
last comment of you flossing
like, not flossing
anymore. (audience laughs)
Saw you working at the
fucking bank this weekend.
(audience laughs)
I'm very, and I don't mean kind of,
I'm substantially worried about this
because I think we're
talking about a generation
that was over-coddled
by modern-day parenting
who don't look at
adversity as a good thing,
they look at it as a bad thing.
I saw a lot of you react.
I'm telling you with my whole soul.
Go meet anybody who's
known me for 40 years.
I love losing.
I love it.
Fucking love it.
I live for it.
Here's why.
'Cause I think I deserve it.
If I play you one-on-one and you beat me,
I love merit of the game.
It's why I love entrepreneurship.
I like when my companies
fail or my strategies fail
or we lose a client.
I love it.
I mean it.
I mean it, I mean it, I mean it.
Literally, another text.
By the way, this is the most intense part,
back to what you said earlier
about being an entrepreneur.
If you're actually an entrepreneur,
meaning like, it's your company,
all your day is is a buncha shit.
You're the last line of defense.
Along with the fuckin'
context out of place
that I have to deal with personally,
I get another text that we
lost a piece of business,
650,000 in revenue, and I
knew we were gonna lose it.
And I couldn't get around to fixing it.
Because I'm the CEO, I
gotta lotta shit going on.
And I loved it.
Because I was like, mm hmm, I knew it.
I couldn't get to it.
I shoulda got to it.
I did a buncha other dumb shit.
I'm doing this fucking
stupid thing instead of it
if that's what I cared about.
(audience laughs)
I'm being serious.
I don't have to.
Your actions manifest its reality.
I think it's what I'm most worried about
with these kids that are gonna fail
and can't be fake entrepreneurs
on Instagram anymore
is they weren't brought
up in an environment
where losing was good.
They were brought in an
environment where losing was bad.
And that's something I wanna change.
I think we have to stop
giving seventh-place trophies.
It's bad for kids.
I told my son the other day,
my son is all about sports now.
I told him right to his beautiful
little face the other day,
he said to me, dad, how old
am I gonna be when I can dunk?
I said, bro, you're never gonna dunk.
(audience laughs)
He said, why?
I said, genetics.
(audience laughs)
- But tennis is great.
- Or he might buy a basketball team,
(audience laughs)
but what's really fun,
and this is now me
going through it, right?
Hypothesis are cute,
execution's different.
Listening to him three weeks later
play with one of his friends
and he's telling his friend
to take jump shots, like he's like,
no, no, let's go out here and take shots
and he goes, because we're never gonna,
he put it on him, too. (audience laughs)
That kid won't dunk either, but...
(audience laughs)
But he goes, 'cause we're never gonna dunk
and the kid goes, why?
And he goes, 'cause my dad told me.
And I just keep playing
it over in my mind.
Me being radically canderous
with him is gonna help him.
It's gonna help him be a human
that can deal with adversity
and things that don't come,
like, life, and it's
gonna help him actually
in something he's passionate about
because if he just stays on the outside,
he can be a nice little, you
know, pickup basketball player
if he doesn't play around the rim
like every other idiot
that never gets to dunk
and actually works on a fuckin' jump shot.
I don't know, this is something
we need to bring back into society.
Merit, accountability.
We need to put these on pedestals,
not over-coddling fake environments.
You know how many kids'
startups are being funded
by their parents but nobody's saying shit?
And then that same kid's
shitting on their parents.
I mean, there's so much
fucked up shit goin' on.
(audience laughs)
This is why I love the internet.
It's exposing.
It's getting hard to hide.
And it's gonna get harder,
and harder, and harder,
and everybody's gonna hate it
because everybody's living life
because of shadows but when you
get to the other side of it,
when we stop being hypocrites
'cause we know that
everybody sucks at shit
and everybody's got shortcomings,
in 130 years, I'm so pissed
I don't get to be around
for that 'cause that's
gonna be fuckin' amazing.
And I think a lot of what you're doing
is thematically in what
we're talking about here.
It's not gonna matter
how we're judged now.
It's gonna matter how we're judged later
'cause that's where shit's gonna play out.
- Yeah and what I take from that,
bringing it into some
of the stuff that I do
is I just think it's really important
to recognize what you want in your life.
What do you actually want?
What do you want?
When I go and talk to
kids in school and stuff,
it's like, of course the first thing is
maybe I wanna be an influencer
or I wanna be famous,
wanna be this, wanna be that, it's like,
'cause that's what's there,
and that's why long form's so important
and it's so important to
have long form to say,
yeah, do you wanna live out of
a suitcase for three months?
You know, I haven't got a TV.
You know what I mean?
I'm just sayin' you've gotta
show the other side of that
and I think that's what's
really important here
is not just the mirage of what
the kind of one side of it is
so yeah, what do you want?
What's your lifestyle like?
What do you actually want is
the most important question.
- And we're gonna get right to you, man,
but then it's demonized the other way.
Like I'm being demonized because I believe
in work ethic, right?
Hustle porn, work too,
everything runs in trends.
Work ethic is not gonna be demonized
when the world collapses and
everyone's lookin' for jobs.
It just won't.
- [Woman] How much of
your values are shaped
by how your mum brought you up?
- For me?
You know, I don't know
what the percentage is
of the environment of Jersey,
I know it definitely
affected the way I curse.
(audience laughs)
Disproportionately.
The way my mom raised me is
(blows through lips) a lot.
I mean, Freud kind of, like
this has been established,
the environment, nature, nurture,
but man, fuck, all of it.
Like I know it's not
true that it's all of it
'cause there's serendipities,
but fuck, so much.
I am so outlandishly grateful
for how my mother raised me.
I'm writing a book in my head
that I will write one day
called Perfectly Parented
and it's gonna be
from my perspective of
what she and my dad,
listen, I'll tell you this,
I'm gonna share something
also I don't share a lot.
I'm in the zone right now.
I was naturally more
full o' shit than I am.
And it's probably why
I'm such a good showman.
It was my dad's insanity
that embellishment,
forget about lying, that
embellishment was like fraud.
My dad was so extreme
Eastern European like don't,
like I remember one time
he was like, "How'd it go?"
I was like, "We sold 39 cases,"
and then like four days later,
he was like, "We sold 38 cases."
And like scared the fuck out of me.
I was like, okay.
So I give my mom a lot of
credit because the great thing
that happened to me was
I didn't know my dad
for the first 14 years of my life
'cause he worked every
minute and all his negativity
and cynicism and stuff didn't affect me
so I had all that optimism.
But then, I mean this
is back to gratitude,
right when I needed it,
'cause I was starting to form,
right, 13, 14, I'm
starting to really mold,
and I was a salesman.
I would say anything to
you to get that sale.
Anything.
Santa Clause, you know,
like fuckin' anything.
Going through the extremity
of working with my dad
every weekend, every holiday,
every summer vacation,
those 45-minute rides, his
complete and utter disdain
for embellishment let alone lying
completely changed the course of my life.
I think that, you know
sometimes when I have cynicism,
like, oh, he's full of
shit, I'm like, hmm,
I wonder if they can sense
what I was from one to 13
before my dad, you know,
like the gift of gab.
When you have the ability
to communicate the way I do,
you often end up bad because
when you have that level
of manipulation skill, you tend to,
thank God the inside was good,
which has allowed me to manifest this way,
but you know what happens?
This why I don't think I'm anything.
I think I have nothing to do with me.
When good things happen to me
or people think I'm special,
I'm like, ooh, my parents,
that must be awesome feeling, right?
'Cause I understand that.
When people say good things
about VaynerMedia, I feel good.
I've operated and built that, right?
When people say good things
about my kids, I will feel that.
With me, it's like
that's Sasha and Tamara,
that's communism and capitalism,
that's America in the 80s,
that's Jersey, you know?
That's my friends that
I've stumbled across
along the way, but in truth,
to answer your question
directly, the most.
She made it happen.
- [Woman] This is about
emotional intelligence as well, then?
- Correct.
Yes, I am a big byproduct
of emotional intelligence
and work ethic, an enormous byproduct.
Me, my mom, and my dad make a
joke that we're working dogs.
My parents don't know how to relax.
Our default is to work.
We like it.
It's our hobby.
I like to work.
I'm sorry.
I don't want to go skiing.
(audience laughs)
I do not want to go on a yoga retreat.
I'm not interested in being
on Twitch for nine hours
unless I'm psychoanalyzing the framework
of 14-year-old gamers, you know?
So you know, I think everybody
gets to do what they want
and that's back to judgment, right?
This is when I get mad when people think
that I'm pushing too much hustle.
I'm like, you're not
listening to what I'm saying.
I say all the time, just be happy.
Like, make 46,000 a year
and be on 10 softball teams.
If you're pumped at
home, then you're good.
You can't work 10 hours a week
and expect to build a
billion-dollar company.
Don't be delusional.
Just like I have to
understand the ramifications
of me being here tonight is
I'm not tucking in my kids.
So like when they're 27
and they're 18 time closer
to my wife, I'm like,
(clicks tongue) you know,
so you just have to, that's what I like.
Life is fair, I believe in a way that
I don't know if other people do.
But so yes, that's what I am.
- Josh, we have about two more minutes,
so let's leave with one more question.
- Cool
- And then we'll walk around.
- [Man] I manage music artists.
I know you do a lot with
artists and music and stuff
on your (murmurs) and we started putting
out a song on VSPs every month
and we now do a song a week
on YouTube, which is a demo.
We did it on tour in Europe
and started daily vlogging the tour
and the fans can't seem to get enough.
Do you think there's
ever too much (murmurs)
- No, I do not.
Because I think the
fragmentation of attention
is different than 1984.
Madonna could do too much exposure
'cause there was only 37 places
and if she kept doing
it, we would get bored.
In today's world, there's so much,
as big as I am, or as
big as like Drake is,
it's so much fragmentation, right?
Like back to hip hop, you look
at average 15-year-old kids,
what they like in hip hop,
nobody knows who they are
because they're all SoundCloud rappers.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Right?
So I think, no, I do not.
- [Man] Keep putting songs out
and if they want 'em every
day, do 'em everything
and just vlog everything,
the studio and everything?
- The music business is
predicated on a singular hit
that changes the course of your career.
- [Man] Yeah.
- So why wouldn't you give
yourself 365 chances a year
for that singular hit, right?
(man murmurs)
I'm telling you, this is
ideology of the past not,
this is everything for me right now
in society and definitely in business,
we have not yet, as a collective,
completely understood
what the internet is.
I'm just being very basic.
It's a young thing.
- [Man] And changing I
think, every week it gets--
- But just like the macro, brother.
Everything we do is predicated on a world
that was predicated on print
and television and radio.
But now the internet's number one.
It is.
And so every rule goes the other way
because distribution is not limited.
Distribution was limited in the old world
so everything was formed
around that distribution.
In this world, it's in
perpetuity, unlimited.
So it becomes a game of
best, not first, you know?
And so yeah, I think you should put out
as much fucking content as possible.
- [Man] Okay.
- Let's sneak in this, I
know we have two minutes,
but go ahead, sir.
- [Man] One more question.
- Okay.
- [Audience Member] So the question is,
our vision is here, right?
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] (murmurs)
here, so there's a gap
and how do you guys
deal with that pressure,
that voice in your head that says,
more content, more this,
more that, bam, bam, bam.
Because that could be,
you know, a lot of stress
obviously on you--
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] And
you don't move at the end--
- Yep.
- [Audience Member] Of the day
because you're always
saying, I should do this,
I should do that, and then
you're going from A to B
but nothing doing.
- I think if you love
doing what you're doing,
you know what I mean?
I think that's what it comes down to.
For me, I only put stuff
out when I feel like it
and I only hit someone on Instagram
when I feel like doing
it actually at that time.
So it's always just based on how I feel,
like I wanna do what I
do and I'm pretty sure
and I'll answer for you.
- That would have been my answer
until somebody very smart,
friend of mine, Tom Bilyeu,
on a podcast with me,
looked me dead in the face,
rocked me, rocked me, 'cause it's true,
very similar to how you
pegged me with, you know,
EQ and work ethic, he rocked me.
He goes, "Do you know
what your superpower is?"
And I'm already pumped, I'm like, what?
You know,
(audience laughs)
like what is it?
I'm like, what is it?
And you know, usually in those moments,
I think he's gonna say
something like work ethic and EQ
would not surprise me,
that I'm super understand.
But he looked at me and
goes, "Your superpower,
and you have this more than
anybody I've ever seen,
your ability to not judge
yourself is remarkable."
And that's my answer.
Every day, my ambition is insane.
If I decide to sleep all 24 hours
in the next 24 hours, I'm thrilled.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It is the combination of those two.
I love what I do and if today,
and this gets into a
singular voice mentality.
Because I don't think most people
are actually judging themselves either.
I think they're taking
the voices of others
to allow themselves to be judged.
People are like, Gary,
I hear ya, you know,
they're like, I get it,
don't listen to others,
but what if your own voice,
the one in your own head,
is telling you you suck shit
or this that and the other thing?
I'm like, you've taken on
the voice of someone else.
I really believe that.
And for some reason, through
self-esteem, serendipity,
and many other things, I mean,
I consciously, in third grade,
decided to not try in school.
Not because I was a normal third grader,
'cause I definitely wasn't,
it was 'cause I was like,
fuck, this has nothing to do with my life.
And I'm gonna start
working on my actual skill.
And I'm willing to deal with
the judgment of my teachers.
Do you how not fun it is
to grow up your whole life
and have all your friends'
parents think you're a loser?
Because the only framework in society
at that time is your school grades?
I think more kids have
to learn to learn how
to be in a framework of adversity
because the alternative is
why we have so much sadness,
which is parents are
creating fake environments,
kids have no adversity, and
everything's taken care of
in one way or the other,
whether through financial
or delusion, and then they
go into the real world,
and mommy and daddy aren't
around anymore, are they?
- We're good.
- Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you.
- Cheers.
(audience applauds)
- Hey guys, thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to
www.empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three-pack,
whether it's a six-pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.